us now as the Democratic mayor of Denver
Mike Johnson it's really great to have
you and I knowing you from just I follow
Denver news okay it's my hometown I I
look into it and you have a reputation
as somebody who wants to solve a lot of
problems and I know you know a lot about
government and you're a practical person
so you're looking for some solutions
right now you I just saw in the clip
from last Sunday you said that this
crisis is costing you 10% of your city's
budget which was money you probably
wanted to go somewhere else so what can
as a mayor sort of new on the scene I
know you've got a year under your belt
but what could you do to try to force
some sort of new policy that will get
this situation under
control yeah I appreciate it it's an
honor to be on with you the pride of CSU
peblo we're delighted to get to
celebrate you across the country um but
uh we do think there is a practical
pragmatic way to solve this problem and
there are three key steps for us one is
uh we do think that uh we should have
expedited processing of these Asylum
claims so they should take 30 or 90 days
and not 6 years we think most
importantly when folks arrive in our
city we want them to have the ability to
work if we have they have work
authorization when they arrive they can
get to work and support themselves
immediately don't need federal or state
support and the third is we just want a
coordinated entry system we want the
country to be able to work
collaboratively to figure out where
migrants should arrive and where there's
capacity in the same way we did with
refugees from Ukraine or refugees from
Afghanistan we know how to do this we
want the country to work collaboratively
to figure out how to manage that
distribution process on work permits if
I could ask you about that because I do
think there's a lot of people in the
country that would say I'm for legal
immigration I know that we need more
workers but if you do the work permits
without actually securing the Border
won't that just incentivize more people
to leave their home countries to try to
make that dangerous trip across the
border and come here
illegally you know I I think that's why
we're calling on Congress to take action
on what they think the right border
admission policy is that's above my pay
grade but whether they decide to have
10,000 people enter a day or 5,000 enter
a day
the key for us is when they arrive in
our cities they just need to be able to
work I think there's nothing more
unamerican than having someone arrive in
your city and beg me every day for the
chance to work and us to say no no no we
won't let you work we instead want you
to stay here and be supported by
taxpayer dollars for not working these
are folks that are hardworking they're
industrious they have skills they want
jobs and I get calls from CEOs every day
saying conservative CEOs who are saying
I have open jobs why can't I hire these
folks let's put them to work and I agree
with that sent um mayor I understand the
point you're trying to make there but I
also understand Dana's question uh and
you told the New York Times and
six-month-olds and T on the streets in
10 degree weather I I I think America
would agree with you on that but why not
start at the
source why not push for a policy change
at the border so you can deal with this
long before it comes to your
city yeah again we're open to what the
Congress decides they want the
admissions policy to be that's not our
decision I'll tell you you know we've
had more than 36,000 migrants who have
arrived this year and we have
successfully integrated all of them uh
into work or housing until just the last
month and that was because uh those
folks came with work authorization under
temporary protective status through
about October when that expired and
folks could no longer work that was the
first time we started seeing people
ending up in in tents and encampments
because they couldn't support themselves
if people have the ability to work I
think Mayors would tell you we have more
than enough capacity to put them to work
we just don't want people here with no
capacity to work and expect cities to
foot the bill I got you but you're a
purple State and you got power
and you're a Democrat and you can call
this white house every day of the week
if you like have
you I have called the White House I've
talked to secretary my orcus regularly
I've talked to the White House and to
Jeff sence and Tom Perez and we're we're
pushing for those changes this is why
you know we were glad that uh secretary
my orcus actually did that temporary
protective status that helped keep our
cities going through the fall uh I think
folks responded by trying to impeach him
for that we think that was him actually
supporting cities and trying to manage
this successfully um but yes we're
talking to the White House we've told
them we need more federal aid that's why
there's dollars in that supplemental
budget to do that and dollars critically
to add more capacity at the border to
adjudicate these CLA claims more quickly
and provide more security I think there
are dollars to do that we think there's
a common sense path to do both just want
to bring this up so Texas bus population
to various States according to Abbott's
office they've sent 95,000 or a little
bit more than that out of their state
they have had 1.5 million just this
fiscal year acrossing into Texas do you
have some empathy for what Abbott is
dealing with given that that border is
so wide
open I do have empathy and I don't think
any one state should have to solve this
problem alone I don't think any one city
should have to solve this problem alone
I've reached out to Governor Abbott and
offered to work together I would still
like to do that I think what we want is
what would help him also which is to say
there should be a coordinated National
plan for where these migrants arrive and
Texas shouldn't have to bear the entire
brunt nor should Denver or Chicago or
New York work we got 100 cities out
there 50 states who all could welcome
people have vacant jobs if we could help
make them arrive with work authorization
Federal support and a coordinated plan
I'd be happy to work with Governor
Abbott to make that work uh thank you
for your time uh time now but you got
some power you can do something with it
yeah mayor thank you for your time in
Denver we are working hard on it thanks
for having me it was a pleasure time I'm
Steve duy I'm Brian kilme and I'm Angley
aart and click here to subscribe to the
Fox News YouTube page to catch our
hottest interviews and most comp comping
analysis